lise qu'on peut toujours commencer par
une blague donc
qu'est ce qu'on appelle 1000 avocats au
fond de la mer
un bon début
pour cela m'a dit que ça doit être
nécessairement une bonne blague
les avocats ne sont pas une métier frisé
mais oui il y a un métier - mais le mien
le journalisme
dans un sondage récent de l'institut
broders seulement 29 % des américains
ont exprimé la confiance les médias
s'étaient 30% en france
vous pouvez comparer ça c'est moins que
les banques
et les grandes entreprises
technologiques les gaffes à comme google
et facebook
et vous pouvez comparer ça avec sainte
150e 51% confiance en
1979 donc en vivant en vivent une crise
de la confiance dans les médias
et ma tâche ce soir c'est de vous
proposer quelques suggestions pour
regagner votre confiance dont nous
pendant deux décennies il est courant de
dire que tout le monde est journaliste
chacun a le moyen de publier ses
réflexions sur les réseaux sociaux
chacun a un appareil photo dans la poche
de laiton donc ceux qui disent que tout
le monde des journalistes ne pense pas
que nous les journalistes professionnels
et pays honte un droit particulier à
votre attention
donc il m bézy des six est évident de
passer en revue quelques choses qui font
les bombes sur ma liste
nous ne sommes pas votre cousin au
voisin sur facebook nous faisons ça huit
heures par jour et parfois 12 heures
toute la semaine inclus dimanche et
samedi
nous couvrons de même sujet ont donc
dessiné des années parfois par des
décennies
pendant toute une carrière nous nous
venons parfois nous mêmes des experts
dans nos sujets
nous avons contact avec les
personnalités puis sont importantes dans
les domaines que nous couvrons nous
pouvons les contacter et les poser des
questions
nous voyageons nous marchons dans les
rues où nous on travaille et nous nous
montons dans des voitures avions est
sain parfois des chevals pour nous
rendre et là où se trouve l'espoir y
avait un éditeur légendaire du new york
times qui avait une pancarte dans son
bureau qu'indiquait il n'y a pas
d'histoire ont ce bâtiment
aujourd'hui ça serait il n'y a pas
d'histoire sur facebook ça voulait dire
sortez
trouver vos histoires
l'internet est changée tous et notre
profession aussi maintenant
on est sous pression financière serait
forte
les abonnements baisse dès que tout le
monde pense que le contenu de l'internet
doit être libre et gratuit de musique
les films et aussi de journalisme
plus récemment la publicité paient et en
bas ceci est avalée par google et
facebook en particulier
issa sarr a changé beaucoup notre façon
de travail de plus en plus
nous faisons nos recherches
via google comme vous ici
nous faisons notre entrevue avec les
personnes par email aux par zoom au par
téléphone et pas directement
il ya beaucoup de personnalités
puissantes qui préfère exprimer leur
opinion sur twitter directement et pas
avec nous sommes journalistes le
reportage qui est twitté quoi hier est
de plus en plus courant est important
l'opinion et la couverture de culture
comme qu'est ce que s'est passé hier
soir sur game of thrones obtient de plus
en plus de clics ce que des reportages
compliqué difficile et à long terme
je donne un exemple ma carrière je
travaillais pendant deux mois sur un
série d'articles sur les technologies
langagières ce que vous permettre de
parler avec google syrie à l'excès de
trois pays et cette semaine et j'ai
voyagé beaucoup et j'ai gagné un prix en
fait j'étais très fier mais
l'article le plus populaire et plus lus
cette année là j'écris dans une
demi-heure du canapé de nouveaux ponts
un copenhague
sur la nature que king de la télévision
danoise pour les enfants dans un exemple
ici que je regardais avec mon fils
la tentation de faire plus cela est
moins droit portage difficile complexe
et donc terme risque est énorme
ajoutez à cela la tendance à la
polarisation politique
et voilà un monde où nous manquons d'un
ensemble de faits de qualité partagée
est convenu par tout le monde c'est la
crise de la confiance
cela ne va pas être facile à régler mais
j'ai quelques suggestions en fait je
nettoie le premier c'est le plus facile
et vous pouvez le faire ce soir ici le
public
la deuxième c'est à nous les
journalistes à faire le troisième ça
c'est la plus compliquée et le plus long
terme et c'est à toute la société de
faire mais je commence par cette
dernière
la maîtrise de l'information doit être
un élément fondamental de chaque
éducation dans chaque système scolaire
qu'est ce que ça veut dire la maîtrise
de l'information les sciences de
l'information
ceux qui pensent comme preuves fiables
ce qui compte comme source fiable
la logique
quels arguments sont validées qu'ils
sont invalides
les préjugés et biais cognitifs comme
partage comme des êtres humains
identifiées par le sz écologique comme
par exemple le désir de confirmer ce que
l'on croit déjà
et le numérisme la facilité et d'élire
un étude scientifique ou un article sur
l'économie les taux de croissance et
tout ça et le comprendre
nous avons besoin comme journaliste de
bons lecteurs ce qui prouve ce qu'il ce
qu'ils peuvent
reconnaître le bon journalisme est
rejeté le mauvais journalisme et le fait
que nous
c'est pas facile
ou est ce qu'on trouve le temps pour ce
sujet nouveau que je propose dans les
écoles rien n'est gratuit
il ya des gens qui propose toujours plus
de mathématiques mathématiques
mathématiques et sciences sciences si
j'ai rien qu'entre mathématiques et
sciences mais je propose de relancer un
peu les sujets donne au matin par
exemple il ya beaucoup de systèmes
scolaires comme la mienne qui passent
des années en enseignant le calcul le
twin nos métiers algebra à des élèves
que nous l'utiliserons jamais de leur
carrière ou dans leur vie privée ou donc
leur carrière comme citoyen chaque
citoyen doit avoir la facilité de lire
les études scientifiques sur l'économie
de comprendre statistiques la
probabilité le poids de la preuve et de
comprendre par exemple la probabilité
d'être malade d'un vaccin contre la
probabilité de devenir malade ducobu 19
la deuxième tâche certaines comme
journaliste je propose une augmentation
radicale peut-être de la transparence de
notre travail
déjà depuis 2010 est beaucoup de
publications dans la mienne s'ouvre un
examen public vient le 3 project on peut
découvrir via un lien en bas de chaque
article sur l'économie est
beaucoup d'informations sur nous à qui
appartient à
léquilibre assia aller entre les sexes
des nouveaux journalistes
pourquoi nous utilisons parfois des
sources anonymes et on est plus mais je
propose aussi plus de transparence dans
notre travail même on doit apprendre à
montrer notre travail comme dans le
mathématiques à l'école quand tu dois
montrer un travail et comment tu as un
souvenir d'activision qu'est ce que ça
veut dire par exemple
pourquoi
on a choisi le sujet qu'on a choisi ou
est-ce qu'on a voyagé avec qui on
parlait et avec qui elle on ne parle et
pourquoi ces sources et par les autres
commandes avons trouvé les sources
d'information allait donner les chiffres
qu'on utilise dans nos articles pourquoi
les autres pourquoi cette source sont
fiables
parfois peut-être quelque chose sur leur
apport personnel entre john journalistes
et de sujets pourquoi ça ne t'intéresse
si elle a une opinion dans un article il
est mieux de la montrer que la cacher
comme analyse
si nous sommes inconnu si nos méthodes
et sont inconnus si nous bien nous
opinion se cacher nous invitons les
lecteurs de nous rejeter mais j'ai la
confiance que si nous montrons notre
travail comme journaliste la plupart des
lecteurs on découvrir que la plupart de
nous les journalistes sont travailleurs
sont consciencieux honnête et éthiques
la troisième chose ça c'est la plus
facile je la garde le film vous pouvez
le faire ce soir ici est ce assez
abonnez vous à vos journaux et magazines
préférés et si vous le faites déjà
abonnez vous au nom de votre enfant
petits enfants aux amis
la sécurité financière à long terme
nécessite qu'on a le temps pour
rechercher des sujets difficiles et
compliqués à long terme ça nécessite que
nous avons des âmes bonheur et pas de
vente en kiosque la publicité payée ça
nous donne la confiance de prendre ces
sujets difficiles est important les
histoires qui ne saute pas aux yeux mais
sont cruciales pour la société
si vous abonner nous travaillons
directement pour vous et ça si ça que
nous voulons faire nous aimons nos
lecteurs nous voulons travailler pour
vous
nous vivons actuellement une crise la
confiance un cercle vicieux de confiance
dans la presse
nous pouvons changer cela en cercle
vertueux
et nous le vendre parce qu'elle la
démocrate yves en dépendent
merci
[Applaudissements]